bonjour vasile faucheuse
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
en direct ce matin sur rtl france pour
parler de cette nouvelle pac dont le
vote va être soumis à strasbourg
aujourd'hui vote des eurodéputés
commencez vous vous globalement de cette
nouvelle pac
déjà je suis vice président des jeunes
agriculteurs et non son président cette
nouvelle pac j'ai entendu la personne
d'avancer dans l'est dans la ligue
localiser et aujourd'hui nous la
contrainte la plus grande que l'on voit
je ne reviendrai pas sur des propos qui
ont été annoncés mais on est dans un
marché mondial avec des règles qui vont
être de plus en plus et encore une fois
on va les pousser franco-française et
cela nous pousse de plus en plus de
soucis aujourd'hui par exemple je peux
prendre un exemple personnel je produis
plusieurs cultures mais entre autres le
produit du blé et du maïs qu ils sont
vendus sur le marché mondial avec un
prix mondial et peu importe si je fais
des actions agroécologiques si je
faisais quelque chose de bien pour
l'environnement ou si je fais quelque
chose de mal pour l'environnement je
voudrais toujours au maire tarifs ma
production est ce assez c'est assez
gênant dans cette cette nouvelle
politique avec un comique qui commande
de faire plus mieux et produire moins on
va en rediscuter juste après che mais
les voilà comment faire pour être plus
blanc que blanc alors que longtemps au
même tarif que tous vous parler
d'écologie justement ya une de ses
mesures-phare de 7,2
de cette pac c'est
là la mise en place par dont des mesures
appelé eco régime il s'agit d'une aide
en visant à rémunérer les services
environnementaux rendus par les
agriculteurs pourquoi cette nouvelle
mesure ne serait pas au respectueuse de
l'environnement et ne conviendrait pas
finalement à votre façon de travailler
des rochelles canton mais quand on
impose des règles de ce à dire que
lorsque l'on nommait beaucoup de
beaucoup de lignes aujourd'hui
l'agriculture n'est absolument pas la
même d'un territoire à un autre d'une
production à une autre et d'un
agriculteur aujourd'hui on pousse les
normes et mans vers l'agriculture
biologique soit mais on pousse
absolument pas vers l'agriculture de
conservation des sols qui a des impacts
environnementaux assez exceptionnelle et
ait un intérêt offrant pour la captation
du carbone par exemple etc ces règles
qui nous impose qu'ils vont nous a posé
aujourd'hui d'avoir entre 3 et 7% de de
nos territoires qui ne seront pas sur
lesquelles on ne pourra pas produire ou
devra les laisser non pas l'abandon mais
mais en mai en poule sur notre
exploitation pour pouvoir les laisser
sur la tour là pour la biodiversité quid
de ces de ses katas 10% des deux de
cette production aujourd'hui on n'est
pas c'est pas nous qui l'avons dit c'est
les américains en premier et ensuite
tous les autres pays qui ont un peu
vérifier notre note nouvelle politique
agricole commune nous on dit et on est
d'accord avec eux qu'aujourd'hui on va
baisser notre production de 10% quand on
sait aujourd'hui le cours des matières
premières les problèmes
d'approvisionnement que l'on soit dans
n'importe quelle production on se pose
quand même la question de cette
production en moins qu est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on va qu'est ce que ça va
devenir est-ce qu'il va falloir aller
l'acheter à l'étranger à des gens qui
respectent des normes beaucoup beaucoup
moins disant que les nôtres ce que c'est
pas tout à fait la meilleure solution
parce que ce qui pose problème
finalement c'est que les subventions
seront accordées en fonction de la
production du nombre par exemple de
bétail
kiki et qui est élevé à des subventions
plafonné aussi pour les petits
producteurs et pas pour les grands
alors des productions de la poney pour
les petits bouts pour les grandes et on
en est quand même un peu un peu calmé un
peu ses propos quand même vous demandez
pas tout à fait là aujourd'hui
effectivement c'est une production qui
est fait au nom d'hectares où le nombre
d'animaux et aujourd'hui nous ce qui
nous pose le plus de problème pour
jeunes agriculteurs ce serait plutôt
d'avoir et on a pas on a mis un pied
dans la porte mais on n'a pas réussi
encore h à le développer encore plus ça
c'est vraiment d'avoir des aides pour
les actifs agricoles donc ça veut dire
pour les gens qui sont réellement
agriculteurs et donc aujourd'hui une des
premières règles qui est en place c'est
c'est un critère d'âge où le ministre a
été dans le sens des propositions d'un
agriculteur en demandant à ce que les
personnes qui soient en âge qui qui sont
en âge
d'être à la retraite à taux plein
puissent bénéficier de cette aide et
n'est plus le droit aux aides aux aides
de la politique agricole commune pour à
notre avis redonner un peu de un peu de
souffle et re div et repoussé ces terres
vers des agriculteurs qui vont devenir
actifs plutôt que par des gens qui y
vont tous faire impasse ou parce que la
jav en ce sens et c'est intéressant
financièrement d'avec de garder son
exploitation parce qu'eux aussi aient
les retraites les retraites agricoles
aujourd'hui sont même s'il ya une petite
augmentation
il y a 6 mois un reste quand même assez
misérable mesures saluées néanmoins même
par manuellement par que l'on a entendu
tout à l'heure c'est le fait que les
subventions seront accordées en fonction
du respect du droit du travail et des
contrats quelle est votre réaction
je vois pas comment on peut aller à
l'encontre de ça aujourd'hui et ben moi
je suis employeurs de main-d'oeuvre sur
mon exploitation comment voulez vous que
j'aille à l'encontre du fait de dire que
les gens qui ne respectent pas la loi ne
peuvent pas avoir de subventions
salue également
parce que ce n'était pas forcément le
cas auparavant non
c'est pas rester dans le quartier ce
n'était pas un coup presque
d'élémentaire aujourd'hui
c'est devenu un prêt supplémentaire est
ce qu'ils peuvent avec tact iv comment
ils mettent active et aujourd'hui des
agriculteurs qui se sont fait prendre et
il y en a eu un alors ça reste toujours
très très marginale mais il ya eu
quelques agriculteurs d'année dernière
qui se sont fait attraper la main 25
avec des populations avec des personnes
qui travaillaient sur les exploitations
qui n'étaient pas déclarés mais il y a
exactement la même chose dans les faits
il ya exactement la même chose dans
l'artisanat les mêmes choses que
probablement dans votre nouveau métier
de journaliste donc aujourd'hui quand
les chants se font se font attraper pour
du travail dissimulé c'est la loi qui
régit et c'est la loi qui met des
amendes aujourd'hui en plus d'avoir des
amendes de l'état en aura
on aura une suppression des aides
politiques agricoles
soit mais je pense que déjà quand on
prend deux le canton prendre les taxes
que l'état les amendes que l'état nous
mais je pense que ça ça détend déjà
assez fortement très court base il faut
que je vous respecte mobilisés
aujourd'hui
bien sûr va aujourd'hui on est mobilisé
tout le temps sur la politique agricole
commune s'est pas on claque pas des
doigts pour le mettre en route on est
déjà en train de voir ce qui ce que l'on
va pas durer réussir à ce que l'on n'a
pas réussi à mettre en place dans cette
politique agricole c'est comprendre
pourquoi on n'a pas réussi à
s'entendre pourquoi le le monde
politique n'a pas réussi à nous
comprendre et comment on peut le
développer pour la police pour la
prochaine politique agricole commune
mais savait que ça passe de par les
états ensuite à leurs rentes et ça
revient par les régions je vous laisse
le soin d'imaginer les les rouleaux
compresseurs que c'est hélas la vitesse
d'avancement on le fait pas en claquant
des doigts donc bien évidemment on reste
toujours
mobilisés pour les cette politique
agricole commune pour aujourd'hui
pousser le curseur un sens dans un autre
en fonction de ce que l'état nous manque
et puis demain de ramener directement
des grandes lignes pour la prochaine
politique agricole merci beaucoup merci
pour toutes ces précisions masi
lefaucheux et de nous avoir fait part de
votre expérience